so in the middle of this obviously we
here at daily wire had been uh
foraying into the film industry we had
released our first film a little bit
earlier this year run hide fight
our audience really loved it and when we
saw that you were trending
um my business partner jeremy and i
we thought the first thing we thought
was number one somebody should reach out
to gina because she's
getting maligned unfairly um but number
two we should reach out to gina because
this is an opportunity for conservatives
and people who think differently to say
to hollywood that
you're not allowed to just cancel
whomever you want and uh
i mean i have to say that i was amazed
at how readily you were willing to jump
into
a project with derelicts like us
and willing to uh get involved in in one
of our projects
uh because it is a unique thing i mean
in hollywood typically the advice is
keep your head down make an apology
maybe in three four years you can sort
of
wheedle your way back into the industry
but you didn't do any of that you were
basically ready to go from the moment i
gave you a call
i wanted to get your perspective on that
well because you know and my
newfound you know finding my political
uh voice you you're actually one of the
people i found
um as as well as a bunch of you you're
actually you're your book was the first
one i read
um and it just really kind of it was so
it was so
simple that it really kind of explained
like the events in such a
you know in such a good way to where it
is like it just felt logical it felt
logical
um and um
so i i'm obviously like so excited that
you called i
i was you know i was prepared
to at any point get let go because i've
seen
this happen to so many people um
you know i've seen the looks on their
faces i've
seen the bullying that takes place
they've quit twitter
you know they've quit speaking they show
up to their red carpets and they're
depressed and they're sad and there's
hard
hearts there and i was like you're gonna
you're you're coming for me i know you
are
it's not a they're making it very
obvious through their
employees that were coming for me and so
i was like well
well then i'm gonna go i'm gonna go down
swinging then
and i'm gonna stay true to myself and
i'm gonna let that speak
and um i think that's speaking so
when you called i you know i'm still
like
my body's still shaking you know
it's still devastating um
but the thought of
this happening to anybody else
especially like somebody who could not
handle this
the way i can no
they don't get to do that they don't get
to make people feel like that
and if i buckle them then
little girls and little boys who are not
getting any rep
like they're not getting a good fair
shake at growing up right now
if i buckle it's gonna make it okay for
these companies who have a history of
lying
to beeline and to do this to other
people and they've done it to other
people
and um
and i'm not going down without a fight
well we couldn't be more excited to be
working with you obviously and
and you can see that the the left is
creating a whole new cottage industry
for us because as they keep canceling
people for no good reason we are
perfectly happy to work with talented
people
of every stripe uh especially after the
left decides that
they are terrible bites into having
differing points of view
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show sunday special if you
did
go ahead and hit the subscribe button so
you stay up to date on all of our future
content